pendant une face à face entre les
grévistes et le pouvoir lech walesa
lance un ultimatum en général j'ai
arrosé qui répondait à nos
revendications dès ce soir sinon la
grève s'étendre à jean paul aron morts
du sida sur antenne de l'écrivain avait
confessé publiquement sa maladie
s'estimer victime d'une terrible
malchance football un pavé dans la mare
cantonales espoir du football entre et
considère que l'entraîneur de l'équipe
de france henri michel est le plus
incompétent des sélectionneurs madame
monsieur bonsoir en pologne et ton ce
soir à la veille d'événements aussi
importants dramatique que la grande
révolte ouvrière de 1980 de nombreux
éléments l'indiquent mais il faut encore
faire la part des manoeuvres
d'intimidation
en tout cas les faits sont les suivants
le gouvernement mobilise l'armée et de
son côté lech walesa se dresse une
nouvelle fois face au général j'arrose
skis pour lui lancer cet ultimatum
répondait avant ce soir aux
revendications des grévistes sinon et
bien sinon après les mineurs de haute
silésie ce sera la grève dans l'autre
grande industrie du pays
les chantiers navals de la baltique
martine laroche-joubert walesa a lâché
tout du combat aujourd'hui à gdansk vous
avec une tactique subtil mélange
d'apaisement et de menaces
peut-être renforcer les c'est une forte
du sens bien c'est et l'appel au calme
nous continuons les grèves mais nous
essaierons d'en éviter d'autres mais par
ailleurs pour la première fois
valaisanne utilise une arme nouvelle
l'ultimatum par médias interposés s'il
n'y a aucune proposition concrète du
gouvernement dans le journal de 19h30
précise-t-il les chantiers navals de
gdansk où pourrait se mettre en grève
demain nous venons d'écouter le journal
de 19h30 les grèves ils sont longuement
évoqué le journaliste polonais en
souligne le coût économique et morale
mais pour le moment et comme on pouvait
le prévoir il n'y a aucune allusion à la
revendication principale des grévistes
la reconnaissance officielle des
solidarités mais le pouvoir se trouve
dans une situation délicate pour la
première fois les syndicats officiels
réunis ici viennent de critiquer
sévèrement la politique économique du
général jaruzelski
ils l'accusent de maintenir le pays dans
un état de pénuries chroniques
il ose même ne pas condamner les
grévistes mieux encore ils les
comprennent l'agitation sociale leur
paraît justifiée alors chacun en pologne
aujourd'hui prend ses marques
le pouvoir à retirer les troupes
stationnées aux alentours des usines un
geste d'apaisement côté grévistes à la
reconnaissance officielle de solidarité
devient illusoire pour le moment reste
la détermination d'un certain désespoir
alors quelles sont les raisons profondes
de ce nouveau regain d'agitation
ouvrière en pologne
il faut savoir que la situation
économique est de plus en plus difficile
le pays s'enfonce même dans la crise
voir le sous-développement disent
certains les plus jeunes rejoignent les
thèses de l'ex syndicat solidarité cette
analyse est celle d'un spécialiste du
problème polonais alexandre smolar
chercheur au cnrs
interrogé par nicolas jacobs se sont
dans le plupart des cas le jeune ouvrier
qui font la grève aujourd'hui bien
souvent qui n'ont pas passé par
l'expérience des années glorieuses où 80
et 81 euros mais d'une manière naturelle
s'identifier avec la lutte menée à
l'époque avec le mot d'ordre avec le
programme de solidarité avec les marines
et pourquoi pour des raisons politiques
ou pour des raisons économiques
il est très difficile de dissocier l
inde l'un de l'autre parce que tout le
monde est conscient qu est honteux pas
dissocier à l'oppression politique de la
pression économique est que la situation
est économique c'est le résultat d'un
système politique qui étaient imposées
après la guerre
et quelle est cette situation économique
la situation économique ce d'abord
appauvrissement intérêts de la
population
leigné les niveaux des salaires
aujourd'hui se situe au-dessus 30%
au-dessus des niveaux des liens d'il ya
dix ans c'est 30 40 % de la population
au dessus de ce qui est considéré comme
minimum social c'est le jeune gens qui
sont obligés d'attendre d'un temps pour
avoir leur propre appartement
c'est l'inflation galopante cette année
à peu près 60% c'est l'endettement de la
pologne envers l'occident à peu près 40
et milliards de dollars envers l'union
soviétique 5,6 milliards de dollars
la pologne se retrouve au centre de
l'europe c'est retrouve au niveau
certains pays d'étirements à l'est
encore aujourd'hui c'était le 20e
anniversaire de l'entrée des troupes
soviétiques en tchécoslovaquie
le 21 août 1968 mettant un terme à ce
qu'on avait appelé le printemps de
prague une tentative de socialisme à
visage humain comme l'avait voulu
alexandre duce vingt ans après a moscou
des dizaines de manifestants ont voulu
célébrer cet événement ils ont été très
rapidement dispersés par la police et
les forces spéciales qui était sur place
à prague comme vous le voyez sur ces
images ensuite une manifestation
analogue sur la grand place de la
capitale a également été rapidement
dispersée les participants ont tout
juste eu le temps de lancer quelques
fleurs au pied de la statue de saint
venceslas avant d'entonner l'hymne
national en irlande du nord le dernier
bilan de l'attentât de l'irak contre un
autobus de remplis de soldats
britanniques s'élève à 8 morts et 27
blessés
le premier ministre madame thatcher a
convoqué aujourd'hui son ministre de
l'irlande du nord pour envisager
différentes sortes de riposte à cette
recrudescence de la violence en ulster
pas remis parmi les possibilités la
remise en vigueur d'une loi permettant
de garder en prison des suspects sans
pour autant qu'il y ait de proches
mesures ponctuelles destinées à
renforcer la sécurité à faciliter
l'action des dix mille hommes du
contingent britannique en irlande du
nord des soldats qui depuis près de
vingt ans maintenant sont dans une
position une situation à la fois
dangereuse très dangereuse même
inconfortables et ambigu coincé entre
les deux communautés protestantes et
catholiques
jean-marc il use philipp etter
une alerte à la bombe à belfast les
cuisines d'un grand hôtel évacuer
routine les soldats britanniques isole
le quartier démonstration de loyauté à
la couronne britannique par les
protestants de londonderry
pour éviter provocation et attentats
l'armée britannique ne laisse rien au
hasard
et quand dans le quartier des
catholiques pauvres de belfast les
partisans les plus durs de la lutte anti
britannique se mobilisent ce sont encore
des soldats britanniques qui scrute de
leurs fusils à lunette les visages d'une
foule où tout leur est hostile et même
si à quelques pas de là côté protestant
on les aime parfois bien ingrate et la
mission des soldats de sa majesté dans
le nord britannique de l'irlande dix
mille hommes environ officiellement
chargée de prêter main forte à une
police locale à majorité protestante
régulièrement accusée de partialité par
la minorité catholique
dix mille soldats prisonniers d'un
conflit historique où se mêlent toujours
séquelles des guerres coloniales et
danger devant d'état politico religieux
pour nous britannique accepté de nous
retirer sans que la majorité de la
population le veuille est inconcevable
céder au terrorisme et aux extrémistes
serait une lâcheté sans nos soldats ici
ça serait beyrouth la république
d'irlande et mon gouvernement propose un
compromis politique c'est la seule
solution est ici les uns les autres
finiront bien par le comprendre
en attendant les attentes anti
britannique continue la plupart signées
ir pas armée républicaine irlandaise
quelques centaines de clandestins traqué
par les services britanniques est
soutenue par une petite partie de la
communauté catholique
ils se veulent les successeurs des héros
de l'indépendance de l'irlande
paradoxe les sympathisants de l'ira
peuvent défiler ouvertement dans les
rues de belfast et être représenté par
un parti politique qui le plus
légalement du monde prône la lutte armée
ici les seuls terroristes se sont ceux
qui portent l'uniforme britannique
vieira se bat pour la liberté et vieux
publicis pense qu'elle est un mouvement
de libération nationale les soldats
britanniques sont loin d'être les seuls
à faire les frais de cette guerre de
l'ombre
la première quinzaine du mois d'août a
fait une douzaine de morts civils en
majorité protestants cette fois ci comme
le propriétaire de cette épicerie abattu
de sang-froid dans sa boutique
oui mais l'épicier modèle était lui
aussi un clandestin membre d'une
organisation également considérée comme
terroriste par les britanniques lui vers
ce groupe paramilitaire protestant ne
tire pas sur les soldats britanniques
mais il est aussi violent que l'irs a
lui aussi se réclame d'un passé glorieux
et entretient des relations ambiguës
avec les partis politiques légaux côté
protestant peter robinson députée
protestant de belfast dément que son
parti ait le moindre lui contact avec de
pareils extrémistes farouche partisan de
la présence britannique
il voudrait une politique plus musclée
tant que l'ira ne sera pas écraser il
n'y aura pas de solution politique
mais tant que le gouvernement de londres
ne se donnera pas les moyens véritables
du combat l'ira sera difficile à battre
vingt ans sur le qui vive et plus de 400
tués entre le marteau et l'enclume d'un
conflit sans issue encore visibles
l'armée britannique reste l'otage de
l'irlande du nord
loin de nous très loin de nous mais ce
n'est pas une raison pour l'ignorer un
massacre nous est révélé aujourd'hui au
burundi petit état d'afrique centrale
ancienne colonie allemande puis belge
indépendante depuis 1960 de deux ethnies
composent ce pays
les youtube majoritaire 80% de la
population et les tutsis 20% minoritaire
donc mais qui détiennent le pouvoir
central
ces deux ethnies ont malheureusement
l'habitude de s'agresser de s'entretuer
mai mais cette fois ci dans le nord du
pays ce sont les youtube qui selon
différentes sources d'information ont
massacrées la semaine dernière près de
24 mille tutsi et ils craignent
maintenant les représailles jean-marie
brad au moins vingt-quatre mille
personnes tuées dans le nord du burundi
en plein coeur de l'afrique lors
d'affrontements ethniques le week-end
dernier c'est le bilan avancé jusqu'à
maintenant à bujumbura un premier temps
les hutus majoritaire dans le pays se
retourne contre les tutsi ethnie
minoritaire au burundi mais détenant les
rênes du pouvoir
second temps le gouvernement déploie les
unités militaires dans les deux
provinces de kirin 10 et de nkosi à
l'extrême nord du pays impose le
couvre-feu à l'ensemble du territoire
ainsi que des restrictions à la
circulation depuis jeudi soir le
président burundais pierre buyoya
d'origine tutsi vient de déclarer à la
radio je cite qu'une campagne de
pacification les provinces concernées a
été mené sept affrontements
interethniques qui a été déclenché dans
une des cent quatorze communes que
comporte au bol ont dit
a été l'intoxication donc quelques
éléments parmi les réfugiés burundais à
l'étranger qui se sont infiltrés et qui
ont sonné la panique au milieu de la
population spécialement auprès d'une
ethnie en faisant croire qu'ils avaient
une guerre civile qui allait être
déclenché les effets sont malgré son
sanglant mais ils sont isolés ils sont
localisés à une seule circonscription
locale
ces deux événements n'ont rien à voir
avec l'ampleur que nous avions déjà
connu en 1972 où les naines éléments
anti patriotique s'était étendue sur
plusieurs connu s'est fait une bande
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qui se faisait
passer à cette époque en 72 après un
affrontement ethnique du même type
l'armée organisait une sévère répression
contre les hutus jugé responsable
il semblerait que ce soit de nouveau le
cas ce qui expliquerait l'exode de plus
de 30000 burundais en majorité hutu en
quelques jours vers le rwanda voisin au
soudan c'est une catastrophe naturelle
cette fois ci qui ravagent le pays une
inondation provoquée par les cris d'une
il atteint maintenant la capitale
khartoum dont une partie est envahie par
les eaux avec bien sûr les menaces
d'épidémie qui s'ensuivent 25 blessés
par une explosion en plein centre
d'haïfa les poseurs de bombes ont voulu
donc frapper au coeur même d'israël pour
porter la violence au delà des
territoires occupés charles enderlin il
va exploser de cet attentat le sont
encore hospitalisées dont deux dans un
état grave
un quartier de 8 ans amputé d'une jambe
et son petit frère
la police est fixé d'un acte terroriste
les principaux extraits sont quatre
jeunes palestiniens de cisjordanie
ils ont été appréhendés alors qu'ils
portent la tempête est condamnée par
tous les politiques israéliens mais
aussi par des organisations qui oeuvrent
pour la musique arabe
selon les responsables de l'ordre et
attaque me contre
tournant vers la violence armée déjà 48
heures de cessez-le-feu respecté entre
l'iran et l'irak les soldats des nations
unies que vous voyez sur ces images
prennent position aux frontières entre
les deux pays
vous les voyez ici s'installer et
prendre position le long de la frontière
côté irakien transportés par les
véhicules de l'armée irakienne il y a
donc 48 heures non qu aucun incident
notable n'est venu marquer ni enrayer
cette tentative de cessez-le-feu
tremblement de terre en inde à la
frontière avec le népal plusieurs
centaines de victimes et des milliers de
blessés également eric perd plus de 240
morts et plusieurs milliers de blessés
c'est le dernier bilan provisoire encore
du tremblement de terre qui a touché la
chaîne de l'himalaya
tout le long de la frontière entre
l'inde et le népal les centres d'études
sismologiques indique qu'il y a eu deux
épicentre un au népal d'une intensité de
5,7 degrés sur l'échelle de richter qui
en compte neuf un autre en inde d'une
intensité de 6,5
la terre a tremblé en pleine nuit vers 5
heures du matin heure locale et a
surpris la population en plein sommeil
le séisme a fait plus de 125 morts et un
millier de blessés
rien que dans les villes de dar banga et
de moon guerre à l'est de l'inde
parmi les victimes quatorze enfants tués
par la chute du toit d'une école au
népal dans le district de daran ont fait
état de 160 morts et 800 blessés
90 % des habitations ont été détruites
l'armée les forces de police et de
nombreux volontaires participent aux
opérations de secours
ils fouillent les décombres afin de
retrouver d'éventuels survivants qui
reçoivent les premiers soins dans des
tentes installées sur place
d'après les services géologiques
américains qui avait enregistré le
séisme dès son début ce tremblement de
terre est le plus important dans cette
région depuis le 15 janvier 1934
d'informations encore à l'étranger deux
gardes civils tués en espagne assassiné
même en espagne par l'explosion d'une
voiture piégée dans une rue de la ville
d'estella en navarre c'est au moment où
il passait à
hors de leur véhicule à la hauteur de la
voiture piégée que l'engin a explosé
deux passants ont également été blessés
pour le gouvernement espagnol
ces attentats portent la marque des
séparatistes basques de letea militaire
en france l'écrivain jean paul aron est
mort victime du sida à l'âge de 61 ans
et en novembre 1987 souvenez vous dans
une interview au magazine le nouvel
observateur qu'il avait confessé
publiquement sa terrible maladie
pour lui c'était son devoir
d'intellectuels de déculpabiliser ceux
qui comme lui souffrait de ce mal encore
malheureusement incurable
jean paul aron était le neveu de raymond
aron écrivain auteur dramatique il
l'avait également enseigné la
philosophie il s'intéressait à tout il
avait produit plusieurs émissions à la
radio à la télévision
il s'était également passionné pour les
habitudes de vie des français et fait
oeuvre d'historien à travers les siècles
notamment sur les habitudes alimentaires
des français
après ce premier aveu en 1987 donc au
mois de juin dernier sur antenne 2 il
avait accepté d'expliquer son
homosexualité avec beaucoup de pudeur sa
maladie il s'estimait il est il victime
d'une malchance terrible dit mais plutôt
où arrivait c'est à dernier 2
pensez à la justice injuste surtout dans
la mesure où je faisais parvenez ses
confidences si publique à la télévision
où je faisais très peu de choses
je voulais témoigner ça me paraissait
une exigence intérieur et j'ai été
jusqu'au bout
peut-être qu'en dix ans que j'y disais
il y avait 1 seconde usage de rendre un
petit service à certains qui enfermés
dans leur ronde dans leurs peurs dans
leur propre n'aurait jamais eu l'idée
qu'ont pu parler si simplement d'une
telle chose et là je l'aurais donné
l'exemple de ce qu'on peut faire ou
maman au moins où je vous parle les
choses évoluent si vite dans les
sociétés que je me garderai bien de
faire des prévisions pour un avenir plus
lointain mais je veux dire qu'au moment
où je vous parle je note avec beaucoup
de satisfaction que la société française
en tout cas globalement à des ouvertures
à soupçonner d avis que ce sujet et
qu'elle manifeste très peu de blocages
très peu d'eau si vite et j'en suis
étonné chaque jour qui a vu réalisé par
elisabeth schemla et daniel costelle
nous avons tous encore en mémoire la
terrible affaire de la petite céline au
début du mois d'août violée et tuée par
deux hommes
cette année les affaires de viols sont
apparemment en augmentation on estime
que 10 à 15000 viol ont lieu chaque
année en france mais officiellement
seulement 3196 plaintes ont été déposées
en 87 ce qui est un chiffre en
augmentation de 10% par rapport à
l'année précédente 1986 pourquoi cette
cette différence entre les estimations
et les statistiques officielles un
problème de mentalité sans doute qui
étant d'ailleurs en train de changer
lentement
thierry calmont céline sept ans violée
torturée étranglé l'insupportable le
soir du 26 juillet dernier un fait
divers extrême qui révoltent et qui
obscurcit d'autres aspects du viol des
agressions sexuelles tous les jours plus
difficiles à établir
mais les mentalités changent en deux ans
l'association viols femmes informations
a reçu 4000 appels nous pensons qu'il
n'y a pas davantage de viol et
d'agression sexuelle mais on entend
davantage parler car les femmes les
dénonce plus facilement
et pourquoi est ce que les dénonce plus
facilement aujourd'hui c'est lié aux
actions des féministes depuis dix ans
pour faire reconnaître la dignité et
l'autonomie des personnes
c'est lié aussi à l'accueil qui a été
considérablement améliorée notamment
dans les commissariats depuis 1981
l'agresseur sauvage et meurtrier rare
mais il fait les gros titres
le violeur incestueux sujets tabous pas
de statistiques disponibles cas le plus
fréquent
le violeur et sa victime se connaissent
et tout à coup la brutalité
le dragueur devient agresseurs et les
viols collectifs de plus en plus
nombreux dès son arrestation l'homme
après sa victime subit des examens à
l'hôpital pour lui menottes aux mains
c'est l'institut médico judiciaire qui
les violeurs
à mon avis il n'y a pas de petite partie
payés via l'air les violeurs qui nous
ont été présentés sont des sujets de
race tout à fait varier de comportement
tout à fait varier d'âge variés
du jeune adolescent jusqu au sujet d'un
junior mais en général pas plus quand
même que 50 60
ils se rendent compte pas ce qu'ils ont
fait quand ils sont amenées rapidement
après les fêtes en général il ne réalise
absolument pas la gravité de l'acte ils
sont souvent quelques fois encore un
petit peu fier d'être passé à l'acte
quand il s'agit justement d'un viol
collectif et d'une espèce de performance
entre en train entre jeunes surtout
vouloir remontrer quand les capable de
capable deux articles 332 du code pénal
le violeur risque de cinq à dix ans de
réclusion criminelle jusqu'à 20 en cas
de circonstances aggravantes dans les
dossiers du parquet de paris
autant d'inculper mineurs que deux
majeurs un mot terrible entre les
magistrats consentement le violeur dans
sa relation avec une femme bafouée où se
méprend pour lui les règles du jeu
changent trop vite les relations qui ont
mal tourné sont souvent des viols très
difficile puisque précisément où le
consentement n'existe plus et surtout
jusqu'où on peut aller avant d'avoir une
infraction constitué pour ce type de
jeunes des victimes aussi très très
mouvante qui vont jusqu'au niveau deux
plaintes qu'on ne retrouve pas après
puisqu'elles continuent leur errance
c'est soit un problème très difficile
sur le plan juridique violeur pédophile
inceste la plupart sont reconnus sain
d'esprit en cour d'assises ils doivent
alors affronter le jury populaire avec
un défenseur
certains avocats célèbres refuse avec
éclat pas tous être avocat c'est à dire
défendre violeur comme défendre
n'importe quel auteur d'infraction un
délit ou un crime c'est pas souscrire au
crime ou aux délices n'est pas souscrire
à l'infraction
c'est tout simplement participer à une
justice dans un pays démocratique
le violent aucune solution miracle en
vue pour atténuer les traumatismes des
victimes
l'information le gouvernement lancera
une campagne de sensibilisation dès
l'automne
oui pour toutes celles qui
malheureusement sont intéressés par ces
affaires vont aussi un numéro de
téléphone celui de l'association viols
femmes informations 05 05 95 deux fois
un téléphone utiles
malheureusement le sport et le football
eric cantona est sans doute le plus
brillant espoir français du moment
mais il ne s'agit pas ce soir de ses
qualités d'attaquant mais de polémiques
de polémiste plus exactement henri
michel l'entraîneur de l'équipe de
france est bien n'a pas retenu dans la
formation qui cette semaine va affronter
la tchécoslovaquie d'eric cantona mais
il l'a très mal pris et ils attaquent
très durement henri michel plus question
pour lui d'accepter une sélection tant
qu'il en sera responsable
olivier rey souhaite qu'un jour sa
personne karimi chine est l'une des plus
une compétence exclusive du football et
que ces problèmes soient dissipés alors
c'est pour le revoir la latitude que
nous avons prises nous de vendre on a
compris
la semaine prochaine et à d'accord aussi
avec le président de la fédération
française de football à contre coran
pour une explication beaucoup plus clair
est beaucoup plus nette que vous êtes il
dit au téléphone en vie il est revenu
sur un si profond bien le problème je
n'ai pas abordés ok cela savoir qu'on va
bientôt ces propos là pour le faire je
préfère l'avoir simplement que par
téléphone
c'est jamais très agréable et très
jamais très facile et puis je crois
aussi qu'il faut il était tombé un peu
la pression et qui réalise aussi
l'ampleur de tout ce qu'il a dit est
lancé dans quelques jours ils gardent
une attitude le sport le vrai celui là
sur le terrain la course à la voile
québec-saint-malo par ce soir en ce
moment même d'ailleurs en commençant par
une remontée du fleuve saint laurent
thierry boltz deuxième édition de la
course transatlantique québec-saint-malo
4780 km pour relier saint malo et
succéder au palmarès ou catamaran royal
qui après une traversée rapide eu huit
jours 19 heures et 57 secondes
battez sur le fil de catamarans charente
maritime quatre ans plus tard 19 bateaux
cette année au départ des quêtes québec
et puis la remontée du saint-laurent
pour rejoindre les îles de la madeleine
saint pierre et miquelon puis le fastnet
en irlande le grand favori et le jet
services de serge madec le plus rapide
des formule 1 de la mer mais attention
pourtant aulas la pop de de loïck peyron
au fujicolor de mike birch rendez vous à
saint malo l'une 28 août
voilà les rangs de randon à dominique
leglou ce qui lui appartient c'est à
dire son commentaire il y avait un
tiercé aujourd'hui pour le gagner il
fallait jouer les numéros qui vont
s'afficher sur votre écran les rapports
également le 12 10 hélas quant aux
cartes et bien vous ajoutez le neuf qui
vous regarder tranquillement ce que vous
allez empêcher empoché du moins je
l'espère
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après le journal il y a la météo
avec josé blanc lapierre tout à l'heure
en fin de programme les dernières
informations avec isabelle bechler
demain premier rendez vous avec
l'information 6h45 télématin et puis
demain soir à 20 heures ici même pour
retrouverez henri sannier quant à nous
nous retrouverons samedi prochain je
vous souhaite une excellente semaine
bonsoir
et
les a